Since the dawn of mankind, battles have been waged between visionaries and skeptics.
Skeptics look at the world as it is and ask, "Why?"
Visionaries ask, "Why not?"
Copernicus, Darwin, Edison and Einstein, they were all ridiculed.
People only believe in what they see.
The distance between insanity and genius is measured only by success.
People laughed at Lars Magnus Ericsson as well,...
...a country boy travelling to Stockholm, with a dream of starting a telegraph business.
Those laughs turned into admiration.
But along the journey, other skeptics appeared.
Decisions were questioned.
"Is it really wise to go from the prosperous graph to the uncertain phone?", people asked.
And when the phone had finally conquered,...
...there was more hesitation around the move to the new world of mobility.
Can the mobile Internet ever be a reality?
Time and again, Ericsson silenced the critics.
Today questions swirl around Ericsson's newest venture, Multimedia.
Are you a skeptic or a visionary?